the word spirituality has a capacity to
divide people like few others for some
it's an innately beautiful touchstone
the designator of a special kind of
experience that's so valuable it's best
left reverentially unexplored and pure
lest one disturb its ethereal mysteries
with a cold hand of reason for others
spiritual is just nonsensical Buncombe
have appeal only to adolescent dreamers
the underemployed and the weak-minded
but precisely because spiritual
experiences are so often either
worshipped or derided it pays to try to
submit them to dispassionate and sober
examination not in order a priori to
crush them or honor them but so as to
make them more intelligible to friend
and foe alike
whatever our suspicions spiritual
moments are capable of being pinned down
split into their constituent elements
and assessed with due regard one should
and can get respectfully rational about
spirituality
spiritual moments belong to a mood that
most of us will only ever irregularly
and perhaps haphazardly access a mood in
which practical concerns are for a time
kept entirely at bay and we accede to a
slightly unnerving yet also thrillingly
oblique perspective on existence during
these moments the ordinary world and
it's pressures are kept at a distance
from us
perhaps it's very early in the morning
or late at night we might be driving
down a deserted motorway or looking down
at the earth from a plane tracing its
way across Greenland it might be high
summer or a deep winter evening we don't
have to be anywhere or do anything there
are no immediate threats or passions and
we're liberated to consider the world
from a new and unfamiliar angle the
essential element is that we're able to
look beyond the ego our customary state
is more than we're generally even aware
to be heavily invested in ourselves we
aggressively defend our interests we
strive for esteem we obsess about our
pleasures it's exhausting and pretty
much all consuming but in a spiritual
moment may be helped along by the sound
of flowing water or the call of a
distant owl the habitual struggle ceases
we're freed from our customary egoistic
vigilance and we can do a properly
extraordinary thing look at life as if
we would not ourselves as if we were a
roaming eye that could inhabit the
perspective of anyone or anything else a
foreigner or a child a crab on a
seashore or a cloud on the hazy horizon
in our spiritual state the eye the
vessel that we're usually supremely and
exhaustively loyal to ceases to be our
primary responsibility we can take our
leave and become a roaming vagabond
promiscuous thing a visitor of other
mentalities and modalities as concerned
with all that is not us as we are
normally obsessed by what is
as a result a range of emotions that we
would typically feel only in relation to
us can be experienced around other
elements too we might feel the pain of
someone we hardly know or be gratified
by the success of a stranger
we could take pride in a beauty or
intelligence to which we're wholly
unconnected we can be imaginative
participants in the entire cosmic drama
there might in all this be a particular
emphasis on love that could sound odd
because we're used to thinking of love
in a very particular context that of the
circumscribed affection that one person
might have for a very accomplished and
desirable other but understood
spiritually love involves a care and
concern for anything at all we might
find ourselves loving that is
appreciating and delighting
understanding and sympathizing with with
a family of dung beetles or a moss
covered Tundra someone else's child or
the birth of a faraway star an intensity
of enthusiasm that we usually restrict
to only one other nearby ego is now
distributed more erratically and
generously across the entire universe
and all its life forms
spiritually minded people might at this
point say that they can feel the
presence of God inside them this can be
a particularly enraging remark for
atheists but it is more explicable than
it sounds what they may be trying to say
is that in certain states they're able
to experience some of the generosity
nobility of feeling and selflessness
traditionally associated with the divine
it isn't that they promptly imagine
themselves as bearded men on the clouds
it means that the objectivity and
tenderness
we might ascribe to a divine force now
seems momentarily to be within their
grasp
spiritual moods can usher in especially
anxiety free states no longer so closely
wedded to ourselves we can cease to
worry overly about what might happen to
our puny and vulnerable selves in the
always uncertain future we may be ready
to give up on some of our ego driven
jealously guarded and pedantically held
goals we may never quite get to where we
want to go but we're ready at a bob on
the eddies of life content to let events
Buffett us as they may we make our peace
with the laws of entropy we may never be
properly loved or appropriately
appreciated will die and that will all
be just fine and yet at the same time a
particular gaiety might descend on us
for a huge amount of our energy is
normally directed towards nursing our
egos wounds and coping with what we deep
down suspect is the utter indifference
of other people but that no longer seems
like such a specter we have to ward off
and we can start to raise our eyes and
notice life in a way we never otherwise
do our invisibility and meaninglessness
is a given we can now joyfully accept
rather than angrily or fearfully rage
against we don't quake in fear that we
might not be as somebody we delight and
embrace in a full knowledge of our
eternal nullity and delight that right
now that blossom looks truly enchanting
in the field opposite
we cannot persist at a spiritually
elevated plane at all times there will
inevitably be bills to be paid and
children to be picked up but the claims
of the ordinary world don't invalidate
or mock our occasional access to a more
elevated and disinterested sown
spirituality has perhaps for too long
been abandoned to its more overzealous
defenders who have done it a disservice
it deserves to be explored most
particularly by those who are by
instinct most suspicious of it a
spiritual experience is neither
ineffable nor absurd the term refers
rather to a deeply sustaining interval
of relief from the burdens and blindness
of being us
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life such
as finding a good enough partner and
mastering the art of confidence click
now to learn more